three okay
are you
you know what you have to do right
you have to kill this son of a [ __ ]
hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
going to be my arrow video all about
that grave scene that people are talking
about it's not quite as spoilery as
people think it is but just careful for
potential spoilers from arrow season 4
we're going to be speculating about the
grave so what happened is like the
reason people are going crazy is there
were some pictures from a scene they
were filming for a future episode from a
flashback we see Laurel approaching the
grave we see people carrying a casket to
it Nyssa shows up Laurel and Sara's
mother shows up River Song from Doctor
Who so happy Alex Kingston is back in
Quentin has a full head of hair how long
has it been since he's had hair forever
that's what alcoholism and chasing down
a vigilante for a couple seasons will do
to you remember he had hair at the
beginning of the series I don't think it
was till the beginning of season 3 that
he completely lost his hair they took
him straight up bald I'm not really sure
why they did that but they did it I
guess they just didn't like the wig he
was wearing they kind of did that to
flashback Oliver - they killed the wig
in flashbacks so who is arrow killing
who's in the grave in this scene well in
the flashback scene there it's Sara's
funeral the fake one that they had for
her when she died the first time when
the Queens gambit went down and she was
presumed dead with Oliver and Oliver
Father and most of the grave scenes
we've seen so far are flash-forwards we
haven't seen grave flashbacks yet so I'm
guessing this is the first Grave
flashback now there are a couple people
that have been buried on arrow Tommy has
a grave Oliver had a grave for a little
while when they thought he was dead
there was Sara's grave there was Oliver
father's grave then there was Oliver's
mother's grave and then they even had a
grave for Ray Palmer so this is just the
latest in a long line of people being
buried so anytime they flash back they
could be flashing back to any of those
other grave scenes but the reason why I
think we're seeing Laurel here is
because laurels family is the through
line Sara's death and her burial then
reburial remember she came back then she
got buried again is crazy
so I think that laurels family is the
through line for this grave but I think
it's more likely that Quentin would wind
up in the grave but remember here's the
important reason why you need to watch
legends of tomorrow in the aro 2046
episode where they go to the future of
Star City they talked to old Oliver
Queen and we learned that Quentin died
in death stroke juniors assault on the
city so he survived connor hawke who
wound up being I guess this is a spoiler
for connor hawke on legends of tomorrow
if you're not watching it
I don't know why you're not watching it
but they're dropping some serious flash
and arrow bombs so spoiler warning for
the connor hawke episode connor hawke is
John Diggle jr. he said he wasn't able
to save his father meaning his father
died during Deathstroke's assault
- so Diggle survived he's not the one in
the grave now there's a problem if
Quentin and Diggle both survived during
that version of the timeline does that
mean that Quentin is not the one in the
grave because it seems like laurels
family is the through line for that
grave scene and it seems like arrow
season 4 has been setting Quentin up to
fall on his sword to save his family
that kind of idea that I would do
anything to save my family just like
Harrison wells on the flash I would do
anything to save my daughter Jessie
quick there's no greater sacrifice than
a parent giving up their life to save
their child
Quentin made a deal with the devil it
has to come back around to bite him in
the ass that cannot happen
consequence-free
also on top of that he is double-crossed
damian darhk-- he's working with team
arrow feeding them information i don't
know the damian darhk-- knows that he's
been betrayed by Quentin yet but he's
definitely going to find out if Merlyn
hasn't already told him remember
Merlyn had that big plot with all of her
son why wouldn't he also tell him that
Quentin is working with team arrow so I
think most of the evidence right now is
pointing to Quentin ending up in the
grave I don't think the show is going to
kill off one of the younger characters
who is playing a major character from
the comics that means speedy that means
Black Canary people like that safe bet
that they're going to be around for a
long time I've mentioned in a couple
videos in the last year how I feel like
the arrow narrative like the actual show
itself could survive without Quentin
when you're thinking about characters
that are marked for death just think
about which characters the show could
lose that would not cause it to collapse
on itself like if the show lost Oliver
could you call it arrow anymore
like if Oliver died off the show the
only way you could legitimately keep
calling an arrow is if they brought
connor hawke from the future into the
past and he became the new green arrow
just like he did in the future we didn't
hear anything about Malcolm Merlyn in
the future so he's definitely potential
candidate Thea's cut ties with him
recently he double-crossed Oliver said
that he's going to do things to him that
are worse than death that's usually what
you do with the villain character when
you want to mark them for death Merlin's
already done enough unforgivable things
and morally the show would be justified
and killing him I know a lot of you
still wonder if it's Oliver son they
just sent well
away they had his big storyline about
how they're not going to tell Oliver
where he went
we're probably not going to see William
again this season and just remind you
guys the producers have already said
that the person who winds up in the
grave at the end of the season will not
be coming back the death will stick the
Lazarus Pit will not be able to save
them I know a lot of people are
wondering why it doesn't seem like
Laurel appears in the present-day grave
scenes that they were filming here it
doesn't really mean anything I still
feel like the show would never do a
complete twist like killing off the
Black Canary Marc Guggenheim was really
honest about how you know people really
didn't like the way there were so many
twists during arrow season 3 and what is
a bigger twist than killing off the
Black Canary so it sounds like whoever
winds up in this grave it's going to
have been thematically set up in every
single episode like there will be so
many things telling you that they were
building to this they don't seem
completely obvious by the time they
reveal who it is and when you think
about laurels arc this season I know it
seems like she hasn't had much of a
storyline what transgressions has she
made that are worse than the stuff that
Quentin or some of the other characters
like Malcolm Merlyn have done that would
land her in the grave as a consequence
if you want to believe this picture here
the Quentin's at the grave in
present-day
I would think the Felicity's mother
would be the more likely candidate think
about what happened in the recent
episode Felicity got really mad at
Oliver because he wasn't honest he was
keeping the secret of William to try and
protect him and because of the terms
that his mother gave to him you can only
see your son if you don't tell anyone
about him I don't want him to be part of
your world
vixen told Oliver let him have his
childhood keep him away from this don't
tell him the truth
Quentin on the other side of that coin
was honest with Felicity's mother and
said look I got tied up with damian
darhk-- he explains everything that
happened so now instead of pushing away
Felicity's mother to keep her safe he is
keeping her close so now she is in
harm's way so think about that idea
telling the people you love keeping them
close Diggle also said the same thing I
want to keep my daughter close man or
pushing them away to keep them safe
maybe the price the Quentin is going to
pay is the death of Felicity's mother
just to say it one more time marc
guggenheim said that they're not doing
arrow season 3 style twists like where
oliver shows up and he seems like he's
brainwashed they don't know he had a
plan the whole time he wasn't
brainwashed there's not supposed to be
twists like that
season in most of the scenes that I've
seen lorilynn this season like for
instance the recent episode where she
had all those scenes with Quentin in the
building fell on him she was getting
more and more scenes where she was
solving problems on her own making
really smart choices coming to
conclusions without the help of Oliver
the other characters they're just slowly
building her and Thea and some of the
other supporting characters out into
bigger more fully developed people so I
think going into season five she'll be
in a much stronger place and they'll
have killed olicity because remember no
wedding rings in this scene here in the
grave scene from the end of the season
so I think what the show is doing is it
slowly positioning itself to be the
comic book Green Arrow show for season
five I think you'll be really happy with
where it is in season five you'll also
remember that most of the main cast is
signed through seven seasons on the show
and we haven't even hit five yet so let
me know in the comments who do you think
is in the grave and one last thing I
will say the characters that the show
kills off that it does not bring back
like Sarah for instance they killed her
off brought her back the characters that
get killed off that do not come back or
typically the older characters on the
show while you guys think about that
I'll say congratulations to this week's
giveaway winner cure Zilla please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details you win a $20 Amazon gift card
and people who win giveaways whenever I
announce your name make sure you have
replies turned on for your account some
of you have disabled the ability for
people to reply to you so when you
message me about giveaways if I can't
message you back it causes a huge mess
so what's going to happen tonight is
there's a new game of Thrones video in a
new Star Wars video that I'm making I
don't know which is going to post first
it'll either be Game of Thrones or Star
Wars so be sure to subscribe to get that
whatever doesn't post tonight will just
post tomorrow morning while you guys
wait for that video to post you can
click here to learn all about why
Deadpool owns the Avengers now and you
can click here to learn all about Batman
V Superman deleted scenes thank you so
much watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you